[Music]
Franklin Leonard is this relatively
young man as we pick him up in the story
and relatively powerless in Hollywood
standards and he keeps imagining that
Hollywood could find more original
scripts scripts that reflected this
range of humanity instead of these trite
scripts that were coming across his desk
and so he thought one day I'm just gonna
see if I can do this better he was
embarrassed however to actually ask that
question because he thought if I was
good at my job
shouldn't I already be seeing those
scripts but he went through his rolodex
found the 89 people he had met during
the course of his first year in
Hollywood mind you his job is like
schlepping coffee as one of like his
roles but he thought I'll just ask these
people to help me and he created an
alias because he was worried his boss
might find out that he was doing this
and he sent out a note saying send me
the scripts you've seen in the last year
that you've loved but haven't been put
into production and people did that and
he said in return I will roll up he
would turned out to be a McKinsey
analyst in his prior life I will roll up
all that data and send it back to you as
the sort of give get mix it turns out
that this thing that he created which is
called the blacklist ended up finding
really novel and new ideas that didn't
fit the prototype of what Hollywood kept
creating over and over again they found
really fresh and unusual ideas do you
know the story of a young pregnant
teenager having you actually wanted to
keep the baby I'm trying to give some of
the other scripts moonlight which is a
really original idea Lars and the girl
which was about a boyfriend relationship
with a sex doll is this some really
unusual ideas and and when I asked
Franklin what did he do and what did he
do right he said well I just shown a
bigger light on to a problem or
opportunity and as I was listening to
him I was thinking no actually that's
not what you did and I don't mean to
offend you Franklin but I think you
actually did something much fresher than
that you asked a brand-new question and
then you gave people too you know the
permission to join in your purpose was
just to find original fresh ideas and
that tilt was drastically different than
how Hollywood was sorting already
Hollywood was sorting by this question
which
how do we make money and Franklin by
asking the question he did which is what
do you love and in the anonymity of this
email process I will basically shield
you from the repercussions of not
picking what your boss might want
actually got people to surface their own
original interest their own passion and
then gathering together in that nice
distributed networked way actually able
to do something with it and the numbers
are unbelievable in terms of how many
Awards those movies have received and
recognition but I think the best part
about it is it showed the power of an
individual connected and meaning with
others having that ripple effect
actually change in industry and that's
what I think the profound impact if any
of us are however young or powerless we
are by society standards can raise our
hand and say I have a different question
I want to ask and how do I actually
mobilize other people around those
questions that I think matter and so in
the course of my career
what I just kept noticing is actually
novel ideas can come from actually in
fact they do write innovation is almost
always from the edges not from the core
and the people have been trained the
same and so why is it that every company
who wants innovation keeps choosing
models of business that kind of keeps
them doing the same thing and so if I
could be that one to either come up with
that idea and raise my hand or be the
one to find those ideas on those
adjacencies then maybe we could actually
find a way to drive growth and that's
how my career just going from Apple to
Autodesk to different places combination
of me raising my hand saying I might
have a complete alternative point of
view let me at least offer that to me
saying you know let's at least ask more
open-ended questions to figure out what
kind of divergent thinking we might be
able to bring in the room only nastain
the English dictionary but I think it
should be because at its simplest it
says that each of us standing in that
spot in the world only you stand in get
to count that it means that possibly
every one of our ideas matter and need
to weigh in and sometimes people ask me
how I came to the term or why came to
the term it's because I think so many
people's ideas are discounted not
because their ideas are bad but because
of the power of the person that's
bringing that idea and I was just simply
trying to say actually we need those
ideas
economy in our growth in our for our
prosperity for dignity and so why not
move to a place where each of us get to
count and then in this new hyper
connected age those ideas actually have
a way to connect in scale so that's the
nez part of the only part to actually
say each of us standing a spot in the
world only you stand in now in a
connectedness world can actually scale
those ideas and have an impact in the
world
[Music]